[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space today we invite bill gayde again
to follow up on the rope I thought is
this the first time we had him on the
show I was contesting I was resisting to
the Rope penetrating my mind the second
time we had someone tried to challenge
him but it was very convoluted I found
there was no clear outcome to the debate
however today we we will dig more in
depth about what does this rope
hypothesis of physics tell us and ears
with us today bill gate how are you
doing ok how about you I'm doing good so
now I'm not a resistance agent anymore
I'm not arguing with the Rope hypothesis
we're just having a burger on the
barbecue and we're opening a beer tell
me bill gayde what does this hypothesis
tell us once we've accepted it or if we
work with it well let's first understand
the general context for last 400 years
since the so-called scientific
revolution since the 17th century we've
had only two proposals on the table for
light and one is the wave the other one
is the particle or really the particle
came first the wave came second but the
point is it's it's been particle in wave
for the last 400 years and today whether
you are part of the establishment or a
dissident someone who's against it which
is a minority group everybody deals with
waves and particles and today in the
dawn of the 21st century we have a new
proposal and this is totally different
I'm saying that light is mediated by a
rope and what I mean by this is that all
atoms in the universe are interconnected
and so we're talking about something
totally different than what we've had
until today which is wave and particle
and I sent you that number one there to
just give a overall framework there you
can see that it's what mathematical
physics proposes discrete particles and
you can also include you can
to include their the wave because the
wave is a one-way mechanism just like
the particles whereas the rope
hypothesis says that all atoms are
interconnected and with this model we're
going to be able to explain I think
without a problem we're going to explain
action at a distance specifically but
yeah if you look at the number two there
the rope model of the atom number the
second picture that's what the atom that
I'm proposing I'm saying that all those
are ropes they're coming to that circle
on the inner circle the red one and they
fork out one of the strands the the rope
is a two strand rope by the way a twine
to strand rope similar to DNA that's the
best analogy we can have for it and I'm
saying one of the strands continue
straight to the center of the atom I'll
be arbitrarily and deep with convention
I'm gonna call that the electric strand
and and the other one the red one in
this case right goes around okay and
forms the electron shell that
encapsulate the proton star that's the
model before the atom okay and if you go
to the next one you'll see a how its
constructed I have a difficulty zooming
with my okay well let's see if we can
explain what we're staring at there when
I'm saying here that the rope Forks out
there one of the threads goes straight
ahead
and the other one goes around and yeah
one goes around the other one goes
straight and it's just how it's built
how the atom is built that means the
rope the same rope that's gonna do light
that's going to simulate light also is
what constructs the atom okay so it's a
two strand rope that becomes the atom
you can call them knots in the fabric of
this of the universe of the of the
matter of the universe okay and if you
go to the next one you'll see a dynamic
version especially when the atom is
doing quantum jump in
other words the quantum jump is not a
little bead that goes from a lower
energy level to a higher one and vice
and back again what we're saying here is
that the atom is a balloon in other
words the electron shell is pumping back
and forth okay and by doing so it
torques the roast that converged upon it
and it does so radially keep in mind
that this is a cross-section
two-dimensional cross-section and what
I'm saying is this is supposed to be a
3d global or idea here okay okay so this
aspect because I would expect that if
it's a rope that goes from one side of
the circle to the other then putting on
one side should have an opposite effect
on the other side should it positive I
don't know about positive or negative
all I'm saying is that one atom can
influence the other one because now
they're connected and here you have an
atom that's pumping that there that when
you're showing it's doing its quantum
jump by doing so it's torquing the ropes
that are connected to it and that signal
is light and it goes to every atom in
the universe in other words every
universe pumps torsion waves to every
other atom in the universe because
they're all connected very interesting
it's a model of the atom and I'm
wondering about sub particles because it
seemed to me that the quantum physicist
had arrived at various definitions for
particles that are even very unknown to
to most high school students like
there's quarks there's yeah exactly
well it's a long story but if you won I
could try to synthesizes as best as
possible they claim to be smashing
particles at CERN and at SLAC the
Stanford Linear Accelerator infirmary
labs all these places Brookhaven they
claim to collide particles they've never
seen a particle
okay that's the first one when you have
to understand they've never seen a part
of going and if you want proof I'll
prove it to you right now
go to the standard model and you'll find
a few particles a dozen particles there
okay and what you'll find is that you
don't see a single picture of any of
them and you would say hold it if
particles have been proven what do they
look like
and that's important that's important
let me tell you why because it's related
to their properties if I tell you that
an electron or whatever particle really
is hook-shaped
right then you can imagine pull because
you know you have these two hooks once
pulling on another so you can imagine
how the shape is related for example to
to you know why why I can pull to its
properties or if it's elastic but if
they're all balls little deep beads then
you cannot imagine pool for example you
cannot explain pool with that and so the
shape of particles is important and what
these people do is they just smash
particles they say we can't see them we
mathematically describe them and but you
know and they keep saying that we smash
particle but what are those particles
how do they determine that this one's
called Johnny and that one's called
Peter the way they do it they see traces
or what they think are traces inside
their chamber and they say oh every time
you smash the particles we see this one
this weakly line over here and this one
will call the electron and they see
another squiggly line and what is that
one what we'll call that the muon or
what a nutrient or whatever and so they
give names to the squiggly lines
thinking that there are traces but that
doesn't mean that's an assumption people
think that they proven particles and
know the particle is an assumption
they're assuming that what they're
staring at are particles so you then
deny that they are observing a physical
process but you are retaking that and
you say the thinking of them as particle
is a wrong you it's it's but it's in
first of all it's an inference okay but
second I think it's in it it's a wrong
view because they cannot explain any
phenomenon and if I go through the list
you'll see you know I'll cover that
subject so let's go to the next point
which is light let's look at light I
looked at the atom that's the atom
let's look at the checklist of light
any-any
you know I'm saying that we have a brand
new proposal on the table and a brand
new proposal is that you know we have a
rope and the question is does the rope
mean meet the specifications of the
checklist in other words these are
things that any proposal that's put on
the table should more or less try to
meet because these are things that we
have already experienced throughout the
centuries almost and the first one it's
got to have a body because otherwise
it's not a part of physics it's got to
be an object it's got to be something in
there and again we define an object as
that which has shape so I'm saying that
whatever is in there has some kind of
architecture and I'm saying that because
for example the people who proposed the
transverse wave they say it's the waving
of nothing and that makes no sense
whatsoever the second the second point
there is on the checklist that it must
start at the atom because the atom is
the origin of light so you know the rope
meets that criterion and then the next
one is that it travels ratchet I have a
question on this always wondered I
learned it I school that static
electricity was generating some sparks
and this was true electron jumps around
the atom the electron changing its
position releases energy in the form of
photons that's how much I've learned now
is it always the case that light always
comes from atoms and always we know how
to produce it itself and classical
mechanics say that the origin of light
is the atom and it's Bohr the Niels Bohr
came up with that idea in the early 19th
century by saying look when the atom
quantum jumps that's when light is four
that's when it releases energy and that
release of energy is what we call light
so I don't have a disagreement with that
I'm just saying that with a rope we've
got a totally different model to explain
the same thing that Niels Bohr proposed
and that is that when the atom expands
and contracts it torques the rope back
and forth and that back and forth
torsion each one of those links that it
releases that it radially that
we'll call energy okay that's not energy
they were talking so it's a different
model but it doesn't contradict what
Niels Bohr said in general let's go with
the next I'll return to the light
checklist because I'll go back and forth
but let's go with the next jiff there
straightness it says trebles rectilinear
or stretches straight in the case of the
robe it's gonna stretch straight okay
we're whereas in quantum mechanics
whether you use the wave or whether you
use the particle we're talking about
traveling here we're not talking about
traveling we're talking about torquing
and there's a signal which is the
torsion propagating along the Rope the
rope itself doesn't track and if you
look at the next jiff there what is it
number six yeah straightness and here
you can see that the torsion wave along
a rope is completely straight so it does
meet that specification required by the
checklist on the other hand transverse
waves and standing waves as you can see
are not very straight and discrete
photons you know again why would a
series of vote of particles discrete
particles travel in a straight line for
example think about the Sun it's got an
atom in it and then that atom produces
light right it's sends a photon little
particles but the Sun itself is turning
around it's it's spinning and so it's
like to think of a water sprinkler it
throwing drops of water in every
direction and that's what you would
think would happen if if light consisted
of particles all these particles would
go in every direction they would never
travel straight well in empty space out
there when you're an astronaut and
you're projected into a straight line I
believe you do go into a straight line
right well you you as a astronaut yes
what I'm saying is the mechanism of the
generation of light if an atom is the
one that creates the photon right
and that atom is spinning and the Sun is
spinning there's no way a series of
photons of discrete foot comes out on
the street name that's what I'm saying
the only one that can do that right now
is the Rope the rope would you know if
it's tied between two atoms it does
maintain you know the rope is always
tight so it the torsion travels along a
straight path because the highway is
straight okay the next one is speed if
you look at speed the next ship there
your speed and you can see that the
transverse wave is the snail the turtle
is the longitudinal wave and the torsion
wave is the cheetah which travels not
only in both directions but much faster
than the snail or the turtle why am I
putting this as an analogy because if
you look at longitudinal waves they
travel faster than transverse wave we've
seen it with the earthquakes when you
have an earthquake you have what are
known as shear waves shear waves are
transverse waves they go up and down you
know just like like the typical wave
that you see for like the up-and-down
motion of the standing wave and
longitudinal waves are like sound they
just go back and forth along the same
axis longitudinal waves during
earthquakes travel 1.7 times faster than
transverse wave for from the same
earthquake to give you an analogy or an
example if if there's lightning if
there's lightning we which we would if
like were a transverse wave we would
hear the sound the thunder before we
would see the flash see the problem
transverse waves are the slowest waves
you can imagine so they cannot really
simulate light on the other hand the
torsion wave is the fastest thing you
can imagine there's no rocket on earth
nothing that we've ever invented that
travels faster than the torsion wave
along a tight rope and that's sort of an
actual Rose I'm sorry - did we ever
measure the torchon the wave of actual
ropes that are I don't think they've
done it there's
Russian fellow who does a lot of things
who were tortured me he may have done it
but this is the point the tighter you
have the rope the faster will be the
torsion so if you have a loose rope more
or less loose it won't travel very
straight but you can show to yourself
you know without taking my word for it
just take your grandmother's you know
clothesline tie two clothespins at the
end move one and film it because I've
filmed it okay I filmed it and just have
the rope as tight as you can from two
poles put two clothes pins and move one
of them you'll see the other one moves
instantaneously it's like it's like
Galileo said he concluded that light
travels instantaneously that's what
you'll conclude that life is so fast you
can't even figure it out and I think the
torsion wave is the only one that can
show that okay and then we start with
the relativity principle that light
travels the fastest and we convert it
into your theory and it becomes the robe
that carries light the bill gayde rope
is the the tightest of all the ropes the
constancy of the next yep light travels
at a constant speed 300 kilometers per
second in in the vacuum in space they
say okay I say it travels always no
matter through what material it travels
always a three hundred thousand
kilometers per second now I'll get into
that in a second but here you can see
the equation equation is a derivation
from Maxwell and some little C which is
the velocity of light and it's equal to
equal to frequency times wavelength this
means that if you increase the frequency
the wavelength goes down they're
inversely proportional and vice versa if
you increase the wavelength the
frequency goes down because the speed of
light always must remain constant at
least in the back this is the speed of
light in a vacuum and you can see with
the road how easy you can simulate this
you take any rope
the more you torque it the smaller the
links which is wavelength in this case
link length and you'll have more links
and the more you uncork it the
greater will be your linked length and
the fewer links you'll have for that
amount of rope that length of rope so
you know the rope simulates this
equation this is the equation of a rope
you can't do this with particles and you
can't do this with the transverse way
because there's no reason for you
increase both frequency and wavelength
and have it travel faster than light but
see the Rope limits that the rope says
you can't do that because when you
increase the frequency the number of
Link's gets smaller and by other to
understand what's in the model here we
have frequency we have the number of
other you call them the number of nodes
or number of weeks
okay links and then is there something
like tightness that appears air or
there's nothing corresponding to
tightness did you say tightness yeah the
tightness because we mentioned earlier
that in the case of actual ropes
tightness will influence the speed of
propagation so I'm wondering if such a
thing exists for the mother of flight
you take any length of rope and I'm
saying if you arbitrarily cut this
electromagnetic rope at any two points
that you choose at random for that
length of rope okay all you can do is
change frequency for wavelength and vice
versa
now how tight is that how how tight is a
rope I don't know all I can say is the
velocity of light is a constant and so
that would make me assume that the
tightness is uniform throughout the
universe because I've heard that light
in certain substrate slows down are you
aware of this and uh it could be
explained in this theory yeah that I
work with that many years you know and
it's known as refractive index for
example in the semiconductor industry
and we used to have silicon dioxide you
know glass we called it so a fancy name
was so good not actually nor
name's glass and glass has a we used to
use the number 1.45 but let's let's
round it off to 150 because there are
glasses that are 150 this means this
means the following if you take the
velocity of light in a vacuum
three hundred thousand kilometers per
second you divided by 1.5 glass in other
words the velocity of where you look at
the velocity of light through glass
through this particular piece of glass
right so can dioxide if you take that
you divide 300 thousand divided 1.5 you
get two hundred thousand that means that
according to the standard model today
right of what everybody out there deals
with their say they usually refractive
in this and they say look light travels
at 300,000 kilometers per second out
there in the vacuum in space right when
we pass it through glass light slows
down this is what they're saying okay
they're saying it like it slows down and
we know by how much it slows down but
but you know in the case of glass it
goes down to two hundred thousand
kilometers per second okay but what's
the problem with that they're saying
they're saying you know it's just the
calculation refractive in this is simply
a table that they've created for
different materials and they created it
empirically and it's used throughout the
industry because it's a practical tool
for for industry has nothing to do with
how mother nature runs her universe it's
just useful for us when you say look if
you're gonna put glass we're gonna
assume that light just goes 200 thousand
kilometers per second that explains a
lot of things because if you use like
for example pellets ometer to measure
you the thickness of your glass that
number comes in very handy see because
it's a Persian table but but there's no
reality to the refractive index system
so are you telling I mean the proponents
of relativity and quantum physics have
no explanation for the refractive index
I believe they don't let me tell you why
you've probably seen maybe sometime in
your life
Newton holding a prism and taking white
light and dividing it into the rainbow
of colors in an image of that somewhere
and Newton did that he took some white
light you know from the Sun and he broke
it up with a prism into all these
component colors and the question is did
each one of those colors because each
one has a different wavelength remember
colors is a function of wavelength that
each one of us go at a slower speed is
that because of the angle what's what's
the what's the mechanism in others
please explain the mechanism of how that
white light suddenly slowed down here to
treat yellow here's a great red here's
the great blue see it's a mess if on the
other hand you take the rope it always
travels at the same speed from atom to
atom it relays the signal at a different
frequency means it changes the
wavelength or the frequency or the
wavelet or the frequency for the women
there's one exchanges for the other
there is no change in the speed of light
which changes is either the frequency or
the wavelength now we can explain the
colors of light because we say look what
happened here when that when this rope
gave its signal to this atom and this
atom now relayed the signal to the other
atom or to whatever you're collecting
and light with now what change was the
wavelength versus the frequency in other
words it slowed down in the way that
became longer or vice versa it's a
different system that we're proposing
here okay it's it's a frequency and
inverse relationship with wavelength
okay the next one is the next one is the
next you can see here I took this from
the internet and says you know if light
is a transverse wave you can see that it
fails almost every property first you
need a medium and they say that light is
the waving of nothing they say there is
nothing there wavy it's just waving of
wavy so the first thing is there's no
medium but see in order to mimic or to
simulate light standing wave you need on
a rope you need something you need a
physical object otherwise what are you
shaking there the second one you can see
it's not fast it's very slow third one
it's not straight and most important you
need to tie it at the other end
you cannot produce a standing wave you
know a transverse wave like they say
light is without holding it at the other
end if you let go of that other end you
would not produce a transverse wave so
to be clear what we're looking at right
now is transverse wave therefore it is
not your rope theory no it's not the
rope view what I'm saying is the
transverse wave that today is used by
quantum mechanics to explain some
phenomena for example a slit experiment
or polarization you cannot use the
transverse way because the transverse
wave meets none of the requirements of
the entity that's supposed to simulate
light it's not you can see it's not fast
it's that straight it has no medium it
must be tight at the other end but your
lives are so tied in the at the other
end but in a different way right I'm
sorry your ropes they are tied at the
other hand and even with the torsion
Theory from Adam to the two threads
convert and convert convert into one
adamant at the other end they also
converted to another atom so it's a
system made with two threads which those
two threads build the atoms themselves
but the transverse wave is aside from
the fact that it's a one-way mechanism
remember the transferor waves come out
of the atom and go off to know where
they go in one direction only
the lock is a bi-directional system but
you know there it beats none of the
criteria of light the transverse wave
should be abandoned it has known okay
and here you see the different features
of light and you can see that the rope
meets all of them first of all it's
straight second you have the natural
architecture which is already curbing
you know it's a undulating but it's
structurally undulating okay it's also
torque so that part is also undulating
you know it's already a wavy type of
thing then it has wavelength it has
amplitude it has all the features the
rope has all the features that
we've noticed in light ok there's
missing none of feature and it also you
know embraces and imaginary axes because
it's a it's pulled tight the other thing
is that you can see here is both Faraday
and Maxwell laws Faraday laws and
Maxwell law says that the
electromagnetic field right generates
the electric field and vice versa and
then 190 degrees to the other the rope
meets both conditions okay yeah now what
I look at the 90 degrees perpendicular
that's between the magnetic field and
the electric field is that just an
imagined plane is it a three-dimensional
thing when they they think of it in
terms of field or is it truly a
combination of two two dimensional
planes well again what they're saying is
they're saying that it's a two
dimensional plane and let me tell you
why who was it augusten breath for canal
french guy early a 19th century right he
explained polarization he's the first
guy who gave a physical interpretation
very interesting explanation by the way
I'm not here I'm not gonna throw him
away but now said is the following he
says look we have a picket fence
scenario imagine a picket fence for
polarization and he says when the picket
fence is up-and-down vertical it blocks
out the horizontal component of light
and what remains is the vertical
component if you put a horizontal picket
fence now it eliminates the the vertical
component as well of light and now you
have no light and that's what we see in
polarization polarization the first
polarizer allows light through the
second one blocks it out completely and
there say we're trying to figure out
Fred Fred now came up with this idea he
says look light is a transverse wave he
came up with that so now you can't
really back away and say well are these
two plane you know transverse well yeah
it's gotta be they've got to be two
planes that meets two-dimensional
because that's how they
explain polarization that's the that's
the entity you know that they're using
to explain polarization so for our
audience who don't understand this Ernie
what polarization mean and I'm one of
those what is it what is polarization
okay one more time
polarization there's a material called
the most common one is Iceland called
spar okay and this material this is it's
some sort of Slater very thin slate and
what it allows you to do that if you put
two of these right one if the molecules
are oriented vertically and the other
one you can orient the molecules
horizontally the vertical ones if you
put that slate first right so we'll put
it like that my hand is now that that's
slate right okay if light comes tries to
get through the holes of my fingers
right the picket fence right yeah only
only the vertical component of light
passes and the horizontal component gets
blocked out okay so you will get light
on the other side but only the vertical
component or that's the theory and then
when you put a second plate a second
couch spark play and that plate is
horizontal it blocks out the vertical
component as well and no light gets true
and so they found out that cows car has
this property you know it's got this
birefringence as it's called it's got a
special properties this this material
and so it's rubber nuts just like the
slit experiment polarization has been
also a little thorn in the side of
quantum mechanics but the one thing I
don't get is it is my understanding that
the magnetic field is needed to create
the electric field and the electric
field is needed to generate the magnetic
field and it seems that if you stop one
of those lights will stop propagating so
are these plates that you're talking
about are they stopping light well you
hit the nail on the head just like I did
you said exactly you came up with the
same reason and then I came against that
idea if light consists of two
perpendicular mutually perpendicular
transverse waves right let's assume
that's the case right what they're
saying is that you work for an Elvis
saying is that we can block and let's
assume that the horizontal component is
the magnetic field and the vertical
component is the electric field okay
this means that what coos and what comes
out of the first slab the couch too far
slab
what comes behind it his only come is
like comprised only electric of electric
fields and that's what Ivan current you
should consist of both and now he's
saying we already blocked out the
magnetic component of course what he
said was suggesting that light comes in
all these different directions and and
so they don't deal with one wave of
light they deal with many and so they
they try to you know blur blur the
problem out by saying look light comes
in all these different directions and
sometimes it blocks out the magnetics
sometimes the electric but if you take
just a single a single beam of light a
single photon a single transfers wave
then what their theory is suggesting is
that what comes out of the other side is
just the electric field and that's
nonsense and I've we ever observed right
that kind of experiments
well no it's it's not it's not that they
haven't tried or tried if the question
is that it's a conceptual issue if light
consists of an electric field and a
magnetic field and we only have one one
beam one transverse wave but what where
I know the suggesting is that we're
blocking out the magnetic field and what
comes out the other side is just the
electric field and they're saying
essentially that that light only
consists of electric field that's the
problem I see with it okay Merryn throw
instead let me move on here the next one
is
[Music]
that I'm comparing the wave versus the
rope here you can see that they're both
very similar sideways and people say
well below you've done is is really
called the field the thread well there
are many differences between the
electromagnetic wave and the
electromagnetic rope first the a wave is
a concept the Rope is an object and that
takes a long time to explain to a lot of
people the second one is that a field is
also a concept you know and a thread is
an object and that takes a long time to
explain to people feel this a
mathematical concept only a thread is a
physical object thread belongs to
physics field belongs to mathematics
what you see those little arrows that
you see there
those are vectors and they and what they
depict are magnitude and direction each
one of the arrows is just magnitude and
direction there is no real arrow and
there is no little curvy line
what they've done is they just
Illustrated what they see as far as the
magnitudes that they measure inside the
lab and they said look you know it's an
electromagnetic wave and what we mean by
this is that there are different
potentials at you know a long light
along the transverse wave of light
that's what they're saying and we're
what I'm saying here is that we're
talking about a rope and we don't have
to worry about vectors and we don't have
to look at magnitudes or direction or to
see it's a rope it's just that simple
and so even though that they they look
similar there's a difference the Rope is
three-dimensional the electromagnetic
wave as you pointed out is two plane
waves okay
and the other issue is that the you know
one belongs to physics and the other one
to mathematics so oh the other one I
would say is that the wave in a in a
sense is a cross section of the rope
a double cross-section up and down
insightly you know not on vertical then
the other if you go to the next one what
is it number twelve this is the dynamic
version and again what you see is the 2d
transfer standing waves they're very
slow it's a mathematical concept only
those are vectors that you're seeing
there so they have no real physical
meaning and again that's why they have
to say that it's the undulation of
nothing it's the waving of nothing they
come out of the atom they only go one
way the 3d rope on your hand
torsion goes both ways very fast it's a
3d object totally different notion so we
should not confuse the transverse ways
with what I'm proposing here which is a
rope okay this brings to my mind a few
interrogations can we counter light
because if light is a wave of magnetic
and electric field and I send the exact
contrary wave on the other side to
collide I should have an annulation of
the electric field and magnetic field in
other word the collision between two
waves of light should equal to zero to a
complete disappearance of any physical
phenomena is there such a thing
electromagnetic rope ends in an atom so
there's only one rope between any two
atoms you can never have one rope see
we're not talking about a one-way
mechanism like photon discreet photon or
like a transverse wave we're talking
about something that is already
connected at both ends you cannot have a
rope collide against the rope there's
there's gonna be an atom
you know the rope is connected between
two atoms there's only one rope between
any two hydrogen atoms clarify that
because remember your uranium for
example uranium in it has 92 or built
with ninety two hydrogen atoms you could
say right there's more because there's
neutral neutrons in there etc but my
point is that you know
Oh uranium atom would have many more
ropes than just a simple hydrogen so we
gotta keep that in mind my second
question which was is it is it possible
for ropes to be perfectly superimposed
and as far as you say you seem to be
saying no it's just one world there's
not two ropes that connect the two same
atoms in the universe no any other atom
according to what I'm proposing there
should be only one rope now we have some
reactions from the crowd before we move
on Michael Scott says what's different
between wavelength and link length I
think you pretty much answered with your
graphics but no there's none we're
simply replacing the notion of
wavelength with link length that's
that's all I'm doing here there's
there's no change there really no
profound change okay may I continue with
because I've got some material to cover
I want to make sure I cover it all okay
and then we're back to the thirty
reactions of the crowd yeah okay let's
go with the next step which is
electricity this is the notion of
electricity according to the Rope man
we'll remember those atoms are built
with threads when the what we have is an
encapsulation of the pro/con star the
encapsulator
in this case a balloon is the electron
shell we have a row of these atoms
really they're molecules I here I I put
them as as atoms because it's easier to
you to explain the mechanism that's what
I'm concerned about here but think of
these as molecules in reality here we're
going to talk about atoms let's assume
all these atoms are merged one with the
next one right next to it so we have a
row of merged atoms these atoms are
turning around when they curl around
when they when they oscillate like
they're doing they're you know they're
they're spinning the whole roll up I
call it a serpentine so here we have
this long serpentine built of merged
atoms
merged electron shells there spinning
around along an axis and one of the
threads really both of the threads come
loose and the threads begin swinging
around the whole serpentine okay we're
gonna call that the magnetic field
though all these threads that are now
spinning around is going to be the
magnetic field and I'm you can't see it
very well there unfortunately but think
of there's there's a bunch of threads
spinning around there in the magnetic
field yeah
and then the current electric current is
in is the atoms themselves that are
spinning as you can see the electric
current goes in in one direction and
it's at 90 degrees to the flow of the
threads which are spinning around the
serpentine which formed the magnetic
field so the electric field or the
electric current is at 90 degrees to the
magnetic field we have simulated what we
see in the lab right at the bottom you
see the Orthodox version the version
used today which is just a flow of
electron beads from atom to atom so I
what what is emerging as serpentine are
these one thread of the rope what is it
exactly no we're saying I'm saying that
each one of those balloons I hope you
can see the balloons there yeah we can
see them okay so so each one of those
balloons is one atom and think of all
those as hydrogen atoms just for
simplicity sake okay each one of those
as one hydrogen atom those hydrogen
atoms are merged shells they're there
touch they merged like you know hydrogen
gas two hydrogen atoms they merge they
form a figure eight think of something
like that
so all these can merge shells they're
all in physical contact with each other
they're spinning around an axis and by
doing so because they spend a great
speed magnetism at electricity all the
threads come loose and the threads start
spinning around the atoms and that bunch
of threads that wall of threads that is
spinning around that's gonna be the
magnetic field
that's see very good so so there's no
real position of the atom and the
spinning experiment they are they are
unloose thing they're outside their
shell is growing in your theory yeah
what I'm saying is the shell is already
built out of gazillions of atoms come in
coming you know threads coming from
every atom in the universe but there's
only one rope connecting this atom to
the next atom these atoms merge and by
doing so and because they're spinning
electricity triggers them to spin the
high-speeds one of the threads the two
threads come loose and they go around
the two atoms and this spinning of
threads around the serpentine is what
we're going to call the magnetic field
in one direction you're gonna have the
electric or electricity and around it 90
degrees to it you're gonna have the
magnetic field so that's the thing
because I don't think I've ever heard a
natural explanation of the magnetic
field and how it would work I've heard
description of what it is I think it's
the very first time I'm exposed to a
kind of explanatory theory of the
magnetic field and let me continue here
because you know then people will have a
million questions I'm sure what happens
with new theories here you have the
three models you have the classical
model the quantum model which is it
incorporates also the classical model
and the rope model the classical model
which comes really from the days of
Faraday and James Maxwell 19th century
we have electron beads going you know
the electricity we're talking about what
electricity is we have electron beads
going from atom to atom and that's the
model that people usually learn in high
school what they've discovered or what
they claim to have discovered since the
early 20th century is that you don't
need a conductor to conduct electricity
you can have just electron beads go
through vacuum through the air through
nothing and that's gonna be electricity
you don't need a
you don't need atoms to conduct
electricity that's what they're saying
that's what quantum is saying hmm a rope
model is just a twirling in place of
merged electron shells but I'll call a
serpentine that whole line at the bottom
that's a serpentine just merge shells
they're spinning and sit you right and
that's gonna be electricity now what's
the problem with a quantum model we've
got a serious problem with this quantum
model we're only beads electron beads go
through the air through nothing without
any atoms you know and I've got a big
problem with that and that's gonna be
the next two gifs let's go with the
first one number of 15 I think it is
yeah here you have a chamber this is a
vacuum chamber and on the one hand you
have the electron gun the electron gun
is a tip that is heated so you heat the
electron gun and it's supposedly okay
this is this is the explanation they say
what it does it heat it it's heated to
such a high degree that it releases
electrons only so all these electrons
come loose from their atoms and they
start flowing through the chamber to
from the cathode to the anode okay now
in this in this chamber we have an entry
for gas and an outlet that goes to the
vacuum pump so you can pump any gasses
from from the chamber if you want okay
what happens if this is true if
electrons really can travel through
empty space like quantum claims right
then this means that if I pump the
chamber down III introduced gas I have
another Tris II I have electricity
flowing now I pump the chamber down I
pump it down
hopefully let's let's say an ideal
situation we pump it down so that
there's nothing inside the chamber
except the electron beads being created
by the electron gun again you got to
think of this as a machine gun shooting
bullets okay so the machine gun is
shooting bullets well if if quantum is
correct if quantum is correct then that
means that the mean free path has
increased the electrons now
nothing to bump against there are no
atoms inside the chamber there should be
more electricity recorded at the anode
we should you know if you have a
detector there
you should detect a higher electric
current because you've eliminated all
obstacles living vacuum should
facilitate look at the next chip it
illustrates that see if you remove all
atoms from the chamber now you have
nothing to bump against all those that
no air no water nothing inside the
chamber you've got a perfect vacuum
let's assume you could receive that now
the electron should all flow completely
to the other side they have nothing to
bump against we should have more current
that is definitely not the case it never
happened never will always always always
if you want to send you know electrons
across you need to have something in
there you could have air you can have
water you can have something you cannot
do it with absolutely nothing
if you remove all matter from the
chamber the electricity will for sure no
doubt about it go down empty space is an
isolating material which by the way so I
mean this seems like a major overlook if
quantum physicists could not explain
this what what do quantum physicists
respond to this the conductivity of
empty space called the electric universe
they're very famous out there okay a
small group of dissidents they claim
they are I say they're not they're just
a sect of quantum mechanics
they claim that electricity flies
through the vacuum in other words from
one galaxy to another what connects
galaxies is electricity that's what they
claim ok and what they're saying
essentially because see if you look at
the outer space here near the earth like
in interplanetary space if you look at
what happens inside the solar system we
have a 10 to minus 11 10 to the minus 12
tor vacuum range very high vacuum if you
go into interstellar space between stars
that drops the calculate don't know what
it is but we calculate it to be minus
sixteen and if you do intergalactic
space between galaxies you're talking
about almost no particle whatsoever
you're talking about minus nineteen Torr
and so what these people are saying
looked from one galaxy to another we're
all tied together okay what are we tied
with we're tied by electricity what do
you mean by electricity yeah we have all
this plasma out there and you know
there's electricity flowing from one
galaxy to the other through the plasma
well you don't have a plasma 10 to the
minus 19 I mean there might be a plasma
there might be charged particles out
there for all we know but there's so
little so little matter you have no
current if quantum is correct and if the
electric universe are correct they're
saying that all these electron beads
travel through the vacuum without any
conductor
that's what they're saying very
interesting all right let's continue
okay so that's electricity let's go with
magnetism okay and here I try to
synthesize in one one little jiff here
many things so it's gonna be a little
tedious but I'll see what I can do here
what I'm saying is how does a magnet
attract another magnet and the first
thing I look at is the patterns left by
what are known as magnetic lines of
force what those lines of force which
they claim our abstract which are not
real what patterns they leave when we
look at iron filings that are sprinkled
around the magnet so if you sprinkle
iron filings all around the magnet it'll
leave those patterns it'll leave a
pattern that looks like those little
lines are going across okay that's
that's what you'll see and the question
is if those lines of force are real or
imaginary as the mathematicians who are
the quantum people the classical people
are claiming they are they say we use
them just for illustrative a straight
you know why or how the iron filings
line up in that direction remember in
high school my teacher showed me these
effects and you do see a a quanta
for the lack of a better word it's not
the continuous effect the I run things
align in run in circular manner and the
question is what are we talking about
spirits are spirits lining those iron
filings
I mean iron filings are matter you know
and iron filing has a certain weight has
a certain size you know it's not a lot
of nothing it's something right and here
you have this nothing these lines of
force and they have a power they're
abstract according to you know the
establishment and it turns out that
these these abstractions have the
ability to align all these real things
known as iron filings that's nonsense
those lines of force are real in fact
they cause attraction and they cause
repulsion between magnets it's those
those lines of force that do the trick
they have to be real the fact that we
can't see them the fact that we can't
touch them doesn't mean that they're not
there they just function at a different
level they function in a world that
deals with threads and you know atoms
cannot really do anything with threads
it's the other way around threads will
affect threads but atoms cannot affect
threads so here you have these threads
and they're swinging around they're
swinging around not towards your face
they're swinging around left to right or
east to west see there so so the threads
are moving in that direction moving east
to west or left to right in that
direction okay or in this case right to
left okay that's how the threads are
moving how can we explain attraction and
repulsion with this mechanism with this
proposal and I'm saying right at the
bottom right at the last uh part of the
GF let's wait for in a second here it's
almost it's coming up the next one right
after this if you can see a real quick
no it's the next one sorry
on the right you can see the the threads
clashing and on the left you can see how
they latch onto each other in pool so
price mechanism we have a mechanism for
how the threads see one thread is coming
up like that let's see if I can do this
like it see what is known and what is
coming down the other ones coming up and
and that grabs and then the other one
they they clash and they push each other
away so but the difference is around by
turning the magnet around what you've
done is taking the top part of the
magnet and turning it from clockwise to
counterclockwise and now yeah now they
clash that's why they push each other
away so now we have a physical mechanism
that explains how a magnet attracts and
how a magnet because is another for
people who are used to street fights
since the difference between doing and
doing things you gotta think about for
the new generation wait wait till we get
to this guy the new generation we got a
look at you know the matrix generation
and you got you know if you're gonna use
your ray gun you no longer can think of
in terms of you shooting bullets you
press that button on your ray gun or on
your you know a light sword or whatever
and it turns out that the light that
comes out of it so she's already
connected to you to your body that atom
is already connected to your body all
you're doing is torquing the Rope at a
higher frequency that's all you're doing
since a different mechanism we got to
think in different terms here game for
this set up okay let's go with gravity
the next one here we have professor
Richard Muller and he's a professor at
what is it Berkeley and he says the
following in one of these his
presentation this gives a good
introduction to gravity
he says so for example if you have the
earth there's a big mass here talking
about the earth he put the Big M for the
earth there and he drew a little old man
there that's you and you have you with
your little mass here right every atom
on earth is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it the amazing
thing about gravity is that it goes
right through things but there's only
one way to explain that and that's every
atom is connected to every other atom if
you look at gravity today though the way
it's explained by a general relativity
and by quantum mechanics doesn't explain
but general relativity you'll see it in
the next Jeff there all right general
theory explains gravity is warped space
so here we have the Sun and we have the
earth going around and the Sun weighs
down the canvas already introducing
force there but let's let's forget about
that for a second the mechanism is that
the Sun pushes down the canvas and
creates a bowl we have a roulette and
the earth is the little ball going
around the roulette
that's the mechanism that general
relativity proposes for gravity what
does quantum proposed particles the one
on the upper left
it says not it doesn't propose it for
for the earth but for I'm sorry for
cosmic scenarios for macro scenarios it
proposes this mechanism for here earthly
scenarios for the micro-sim world in
other words they're they're using the
graviton the graviton particle and here
just put it in in the in the context of
the cosmic you know in a cosmic scenario
and I'm saying look if the Sun were to
throw particles at the earth how does
that attract the earth if it throws
particles at it the other one is there
when on the right upper right and that's
also based on particles but the
particles instead of coming out of the
Sun and hitting the earth the particles
are outside the earth and the Sun
pushing the earth towards the Sun under
any person actually believing in this
one yeah
you have people it's it's known as
really the Casimir effect if you take
two plates this is the explanation okay
you take two plates and you remove the
particles in between them the particles
on outside of the plates push the two
plates inwards that's customary so they
do have these explanations out there and
I'm saying all this is nonsense
look at the if you put that one back
again you'll see the rope model at the
bottom the Earth spins the earth around
because every atom on earth is connected
physically connected to every atom that
comprises the Sun and so you know the
earth iseven just swings the earth
around like a bunch of lily putty ins
would swing Gulliver around at the end
of a bunch of ropes that's how that's
how it is or a kid you know just
swinging a ball around himself that's
what it is
now a question emerges it's a much
simpler mechanism than the mathematical
models that they created you know for
work space particles and brushes a
question emerges in my mind how does
your theory deal with displacement at
speeds suppose I was to accelerate the
earth toward the Sun what's okay to the
rope here well the issue remember you
have a significant force here because
the Sun is swinging the earth I have a
little ball always I found one with a
straight you know you see that yeah okay
so we can understand this you know if
you swing this ball around I'll make it
smaller so then fits within the camera
if we swing me the earth around right
that's how it does it there's a there's
a centrifugal force from the motion from
the what is called the angular momentum
and then the string the ropes all the
ropes from the ball connected to all the
roof from the earth connected to all the
ropes and to every atom in the in the
Sun that's that's the string that's the
analogy here you the string is is the
analogy for all those ropes so the
string doesn't let the ball get out but
at the same time it's the angular
momentum of the speed of the earth
movement of the sun's curling
the earth around itself and all the
other planets that prevents the you know
the planets and moons and etc from
leaving you yeah solar says no because
you had to ask the question what
prevents the moon from flying out of the
solar system
well what holds it to the earth is there
nothing there are we gonna put spirits
in that space between the Earth and the
moon and I'm saying if every atom from
there is connected to over here then
yeah we can imagine why the moon can't
leave because all atoms are
interconnected but my suppose that I
have super Rockets like very powerful
enough to accelerate the earth and I
Drive the earth toward the Sun what am i
doing to the rope is there some loose
appearing in the ropes who do we see as
a result of movement speed increasing is
that the equivalent of the blue shift or
the red shift what's happening in terms
of the light capacities between the Sun
and the earth the rope always remains
tight the atom slides along the rope
eating wrong and released behind it like
a beaten and abacus so no college the
wire on the abacus doesn't go without
with a bead the beat slides along it and
think of an atom as eating links of
ropes and releasing links of ropes along
a given rope that it's going through
well I don't want to be an ass ear but
then what if I what if I what if I Drive
you the planet Earth away from the Sun
is there Adam just slide along the ropes
I mean when I approach you you don't
even have to use the Sun scenario every
atom in your body is connected to every
atom in my body through these
electromagnetic ropes right through the
ocean and when I approach you when I get
closer to you and farther away from you
all I'm doing is sliding along the ropes
no but it seems that are you telling me
that the rope that are connecting my
atoms to your atoms are also continuing
past our bodies to our infinite plans
yes the atom that that starts in your
body holding the atom net starts in your
body and
and an atom that ends in my body the
that road that single rope right that
rope I can only slide along from towards
you and you know back and forth along
that rope but all the other atoms some
our atoms are behind me remember if
gravity goes right through things that
means that the ropes are going through
my body from the Sun through my body to
your body okay so essentially you're
taking loose from the ropes of the other
item you're headed toward to give it
back to me right there's only so much
thread in the universe in fact the
underlying hypothesis the underlying
proposal there's a single closed loop
thread in the entire universe that's all
there is
this thread turns into every atom which
we're going to call knots and into every
neutron I'm saying there are neutrons
some people don't like that idea but and
then in between you have ropes those
same threads so there's a single thread
in the entire unit that's all there is
fascinating it seems that it does
challenge some classical notions of
traveling if I if I'm at the periphery
of the universe because I'm like that I
like to live in cold regions I like to
get away from civilization it does seem
that if I get away from the observable
universe traveling toward the empty
space is going to be hard yeah we
discuss it
what's at the edge of the universe as we
call right remember space is nothing
there is no such thing as fate and I
define space as that which has no shape
and it's the opposite of an object which
is that which has shape so we have that
which has no shape and that which has
shape so space is now we don't have to
worry about space space is not really
part of physics only in physics only
deals with the objects and the issue
here is the fine what's at the edge of
matter that ball of matter if you had
God's eyes and you could look at the
entire universe from afar for example
what's at the edge of that universe and
I'm saying what you'll find at the edge
of the universe is the same thing you'll
find here at the edge of Earth in other
words what you'll find is swinging
threads which is the magnetic
field that covers the planet that's what
you'll find at the edge of the universe
manaphy was there any other just to
finish up on gravity here just got to
what is it so this is the mechanism that
I'm proposing the earth is swung around
by the Sun because every atom is in turn
is connected to every atom from the
earth is connected to every atom of the
Sun and if you go to the next idea if
they're the last one I know that's the
first one there's a number 20 for some
reason I don't have it but maybe I can
check back into what you're not so
important I was just showing the
mechanism of gravity if every atom from
from one object is let's see if I can
simulate it here actually it's an
animated gif and it's okay as you can
see the ropes when you're far away the
ropes form 1:1 coaxial they come
together next and that's one let's get
the next one there all right well it's
sunny made that so I have to wait
through every year okay so all atoms are
interconnected from two objects and then
the further away they are the roads come
together the closer they are the ropes
fan out that's the mechanism of that I'm
proposing for acceleration of gravity
and you can see it also drops the
through the threads the ropes I'm sorry
the ropes
fan out sometimes maybe you'll get an
idea of what mechanism I'm proposing all
atoms are interconnected the farther
they are though the closer they come
together the closer they are the objects
the more they fan out and you can see
how the ropes connecting the elephant to
the earth are becoming wider and wider
they have different angles as the
elephant falls to earth that's the
acceleration of gravity that I'm
proposing okay is there a prediction of
a different
acceleration of gravity depending on
your distance from the earth of course
of course you got to remember one thing
and this is the term called weight you
know when you say what is weight and
weight is something that's a lot of
people have not figured out you know if
you have if you have an atom just one
atom hydrogen atom and it's a I don't
know ten thousand kilometers from the
center of the earth in one direction
specifically and we're gonna assume the
earth is a perfectly spherical ball okay
just for the sake of argument so it's a
uniform okay so we have a little
particle we will call a hydrogen atom
and it's connected to the earth by all
the ropes that connect to every atom
that comprises the earth right that's
the that's the proposal as as soon as
soon as that atom takes one step forward
is one centimeter closer to the earth
it's weight has changed because now more
ropes have fanned out from that point
farther away and I give it so so weight
is location dependent
okay weight is location the baby cause
it depends on the number of what I call
effective ropes the number of ropes that
are pulling independently as a body
approaches the earth when an astronaut
or say a parachutist falls to earth all
those ropes open up and that's because
it the acceleration you have more and
more ropes pulling from different angles
every from every atom on earth like mr.
Butler explained there and and so you
know you have more and more ropes the
closer you are to the center of the
earth that's the acceleration of gravity
under my model very interesting so is
there any concluding remarks or do we
have time to get through the reactions
of the crowd yeah let me just conclude
real quickly the following I'm saying
the following today then maile point
today was a funny with a rope I can
explain sir several basic right basic
features of the atom I can explain basic
features of light
of electricity magnetism and gravity I
think as a minimum what I called my soft
conclusion as a minimum the Rope should
be considered side by side should be at
least regarded side by side with the
particle end on the transverse wave as a
minim it's it's earned that right to say
well it's worth looking into maybe I
can't explain every phenomena in the
universe you know there's so many things
you want out there but I think as a
minimum syn synack it can explain it in
irrational manners each one of these
features as a minimum it deserves
consideration absolutely I fully agree
that's why I love hearing from you a
crusader memetics says make sure to have
been crushed black hole theory and the
pre Stone Age understanding of
diffraction that's actually what
happened today I was in the afternoon I
was thinking about the ropes and I ended
up thinking what if a photon is orbiting
around the black hole is that a rope and
does the end of the rope reconnect back
to itself in some circular way I think
clarifies a lot first of all you know
black holes supposedly right it used to
be a star it's a Norma star that
compressed because it had so much manner
it compressed to the point where it
became a singularity it crushed all
matter out of existence let me say that
again because that's important it
crushed all matter out of existence
there's only mass so we have mass but
see mass is the quantity of matter and
so we have a circular reasoning we
crushed all matter out of existence
there's only mass but mass is the
quantity of matter we got a problem
there there's a bigger problem
supposedly the black hole right
influences a star nearby that's how they
they see a black that's how they detect
black hole so you say look look what's
happening to that star that we can see
what's happening to it it's going to
around a circle oh it's got to be a
black hole in the center of that
circumference and look at that other
star it's losing its gaseous skin
what's sucking it oh it's got to be a
black hole and haven't seen black hole
what's the problem the problem is that a
black hole is all mass in no manner it's
just a singularity of mathematical
singularity and you cannot say that mass
did the trick you cannot say that mass
made a star go around you cannot say
that mass pulled the skin the guests
from the surface of a star from far away
you cannot say you can say a dog did it
you can say you had rocked it you can
say a vacuum cleaner did it you cannot
say that mass did it because mass is a
concept what the mathematicians have
done is turned the whole thing around
they say look every time we see this we
know it's related to mass that means
that there's got to be a big mass there
pulling on that thing somehow but
they're not explaining the mechanism
they're just describing it
mathematically saying oh the more mass
we have this is the effect but you
cannot use mass as a mechanism say mass
did this and mass did that that's the
problem with the black hole no but you
agree that there's a supermassive object
at the center of galaxies right no no
what spin there's a different mechanism
which I propose for what is known as the
black fault hole phenomenon whether
whether we're talking about sucking
gases from the from a star or making a
star twirled around both of them are
done by the magnetic field of the galaxy
it's so powerful if you take if you take
a charged particle in a lab you can do
this in the lab here here on earth
take a charged particle and put it in a
magnetic field so we have those magnetic
field coming down for example that
charged particle will move around in
circles and that's what's happening to a
star that's under the influence of the
magnetic field of the galaxy the galaxy
the magnetic field is sweeping down and
this charged particle called the Sun is
turning around in circles and likewise
that same magnetic
field is the one that in certain regions
because in those regions the magnetic
field is very intense is sucking or
removing the gas the gas gaseous matter
from its service if you take a if you
take smoke just take smoke in in the lab
you can do that there I've got a video
on this but if you take smoke in it any
land and you put it close to a magnetic
field the magnetic field will move the
smoke and they'll suck it in and that's
exactly what the magnetic field of the
galaxy is doing to a star's gases
service so do you think that the center
of galaxies is essentially non massive
or at best
a little star but nothing very massive
absolutely now what we have is going
through there is the magnetic field just
like the magnetic field goes through the
centre of the earth and out the other
side at the other the edges of the earth
and coming back in it's you know it does
that in a circular fashion all around
the earth and a magnetic field of the
galaxy is the same thing and and talking
about galaxies because we got to look at
dark matter in conjunction with the
black hole the reason you know the
reason the stars don't go flying out of
the little galaxy is because they're all
connected all the atoms are connected so
the whole galaxy pearls like a like a
carousel
that's why galaxies don't break apart
and that's why stars at the edge of the
universe at the edge of a galaxy sorry
go just as fast as those on the inside
known as the galaxy rotation problem
because they're all connected know
physically connected wow that that is
absolutely stunning I mean I cannot even
begin to to go through the consequences
of this but if that is correct
it changes totally our view of the
universe cubic well for us is Aaron
shear waves just deflected longitudinal
waves well wave remember is is like
sound it just goes along a given axis
back and forth its rear faction and and
the compression of light
the sound son is the typical example
where you know it hits your ear but
what's hitting area what's hitting your
ear is air the air is what's vibrating
and that's why we can hear sound and the
issue is that you must have a physical
entity to mediate a longitudinal wave so
we cannot talk about transverse wave or
longitudinal waves without identifying
what is it that is waving
that's what we're doing here with a rope
we're saying look the Rope is a physical
entity you don't believe me go to the
hardware store and ask for a rope you'll
find that they'll sell you something in
your hand but asking for a longitudinal
wave or a transverse wave and see what
they give you and chemically foie gras
is to ask can ropes intersect
I have several answers for that if you
allow me because it's a very large
question so if I may because so people
understand what the problem is with with
that question it's it's a can of worms
and so it needs careful attention and so
let's go step by step here okay the
first answer I have I have at least four
answers for that so here's the first one
okay let me finish with each answer the
first answer is it's a premature
question
it's a premature question because of the
following what I presented today is the
basics that I'm saying look does the
rope simulate light does the rope
simulate magnetism does the rope
simulate gravity and electricity if the
answer is no let's assume you you decide
that no it doesn't in your opinion well
then we don't have to ask the question
of what a rope is made out of does it
stretch from here all the way to the
Andromeda galaxy we don't have to ask
any more questions because the Rope
doesn't meet any other conditions okay
that's the first issue
the second issue the second issue is
that we have to know in order to
understand my answer to that question
you need to understand my language and I
create a new language I'll have to agree
with that people accuse me and say you'd
better new legs I say yeah I'd better
new language
it was necessary because no one has
defined the foundations of physics in
the last 10,000 years
physics requires an object you can't do
physics without an object if God comes
in and erases all the matter from the
universe
you're not seeing anything there's
nothing happening no one in the last
10,000 years defined the word object for
the purposes of physics don't take my
word for it just pick up any textbook of
physics the one who studied in high
school go to the library or whatever and
you will find the following you will
find no one begins by saying an object
is this this is the definition of energy
that's the first one second has no one
noticed even though how important it is
to define the word object for the
purposes of physics and and there are
other words you need to know what
location means you need to know what
motion means you need to know what
exists is physics is the science of
existence physics only studies that
which exists and none of these words
have ever been defined and you say bill
what's that got to do with my question
well that goes to the third issue the
third issue goes as follows before a
road can cut across another rope okay
listen carefully here before a rope and
cut it across another rope it must touch
it okay so here I mean simulator I got
my rope always here here's a sister I
want to cut the rope before I can cut
the rope I must touch it with the blades
right okay so now what is the problem
the problem is what do we mean by touch
I mean are we going to use the
definition of ordinary the ordinary
dictionary I'll punch ya I touched the
table no we can't use it for the
purposes of science touch means zero
distance that's what some touch means
zero distance but we have a problem
because and this is why we're
definitions are so important to
understand these things so we have zero
distance but what happens here I have
two fingers once touching the other
right is there zero distance between the
atoms of my fingers and yet have the
habit this has the skin become one
and the answer is no but if they did
become one let's assume because that's
zero distance there's no space
separating the atoms they're nothing
then what happens we have a single
object but a single object destroys the
word touch because touch requires two
objects turns two objects into one and
all I'm saying here all I'm saying here
is how difficult how complex the
question is to say do ropes cut across
each other do they tangle you know
there's a lot involved that spirit it's
a very charged question and it just to
give you an idea it took me two years to
figure out an answer to the question
first of all not posting just the
reality and second in my book it's the
seventh chapter before you can get to
the seventh chapter you gotta eat a lot
of words you gotta understand a lot of
concepts before you can get to that
point because there's a lot involved in
that's all I can say right now it's just
uh I cannot explain this in two seconds
and say oh you understood it there's no
way very entire thing now is the object
of your theory the object is the rope or
the atom yeah really the object was the
rope you know you know I was in prison I
was in prison for three years yeah
people were talking about this on the
chat before you came in your Wikipedia
page now for those who want to call me
out and they were saying Jeff why don't
you talk about the criminal history to
me I've looked into this thing on
Wikipedia and there's nothing in there
that shows me that bill is an immoral
person he seems to be he seems to be an
agent of information he wants to spread
information
[Laughter]
well this is it this is what I wanted to
say when I was in friends I was in there
for three years and you know I came from
an atheist background my family was not
only just atheist they were militant
atheists my mother we lived in Baltimore
and we were there with Madalyn Murray
O'Hair she was a friend of ours she came
to our house we would go to her house
she was the founder of American Atheists
she was later killed anyways I came from
an atheist background and when I went to
prison you know I had studied a lot of
religion I study I read the Bible three
times when I was a kid and so I knew a
lot I knew a lot of the arguments used
in in the biblical world in Christianity
especially and when I were in the prison
you know these guys they became
born-again Christians on the first day
in prison they they repented of their
sins and suddenly they all became a lot
of them you know became born-again
Christians some became Muslim especially
the black people and so they would argue
with me and they would you know people
would form a group around us and they
and we would laugh and tell jokes and so
on they had a lot of fun and we were
arguing the guy defending religion I was
attacking it and and so the issue came
up and they said you know in a couple of
instances they came back at me and said
well prove to me that God does not exist
and and I said well you know I wasn't
about to explain to them that the
responsibility was here so I said I'm
gonna look up to see you know if I have
a good answer for that question I want
to really have a good question a good
answer for it and I said who else but
the physicists I mean the headhunters of
the world and I started looking at the
physics books in the library there were
several of them and I was appalled what
I read for the first time in my life I
understood what quantum general
relativity and through the string theory
were about and it just blew my mind and
I said forget about religion forget
about God we got a bigger problem here
we have the people who run the world and
in the science world and they're more
religious than the religious folk and
the Christians forget about them we got
a different enemy here and that's when I
began researching and what I
specifically research was light
and gravy I was looking like gravity
like gravity for a year and a half and a
lot of people would have given up by
them but I kept going kept going until
you know I eventually I think I cracked
the code as ah a rope wonderful look a
bear says people don't think the
universe be like it is but it do
christopher Grimm says are we in a field
of ropes I guess you could call it look
if you take a whole bunch of ropes you
could say that's the background
radiation you can call it a field you
can call it the false vacuum ether even
is very the important thing is to
understand the concept if if every atom
is interconnected there's gonna be a
field of ropes gazillions of them
crisscrossing in the solar system and so
you know we do have these fields these
vibrations out there that we are able to
detect it's just a bunch of ropes that
are vibrating
they're sending signals to every atom
that's what I think a field is that's
what I think the ether is that's what I
think the false vacuum and all this
other stuff that they've come up with is
all right LM says is life energy or
electricity a product of decompression
of atoms is the universe expanding or
folding in on itself I'm stupid and I
know nothing well we're asked that
question he's just been fed something
from the establishment and they talk
about the expansion of the universe so
we need to clarify again language is
very important here there is no physical
object called universe universe means
space and matter
that's what you know but it's a concept
it's got two parts to it space and
matter
now we can talk about the expansion of
space and we can talk about the
expansion of matter we cannot talk about
the expansion of space under the rope
model because we define space is that
which has no shape there is nothing
there so space forget it and that's
essentially what one what general
relativity says that space is expanding
so that we say that's nonsense space is
not a physical object
it's not a balloon the universe doesn't
have shaped like a ball that's expanding
but now the question is does matter
expand our atoms getting farther away
from each other our stars getting
farther away from each other galaxies
parted that's a different answer that
requires a look at but what I'm saying
here is that you know you have to
understand the following in the local
group of 20 galaxies of which you know
the Milky Way is one of them Andromeda
is another one the Magellan clouds
there's two of them those are part of it
there's 20 galaxies in the region known
as the local group those galaxies are
blue shifted for the most part Andromeda
galaxy is 2.2 and a half million
light-years away coming towards us in
two and a half million years if God
doesn't think otherwise it's going to
collide against our galaxy supposedly
okay yeah it's blue shift that it's
coming towards us this means that not
all not the entire universe is expanding
or matter
some things are blue shift and coming
together and the question is how do you
explain that within the expansion of the
universe theory proposed by general
relativity you can't know now with
background radiation I hope you still
believe in the Big Bang Big Bang Big
Bang is a creationist theory Big Bang is
religion Big Bang says there was an
origin to matter and mr. Stephen Hawking
recently died he said that it's created
out of energy we have positive energy
and negative energy
and you can increase the positive and
the negative energy without changing the
zero energy of the universe if you put
these two energies together in other
words a sign you put them on negative
sign plus one and minus one and you get
zero that's what he's saying
and he's saying we have a positive
energy the negative energy and when
these two separated the positive energy
became matter
but energy is a concept in fact richard
fineman says we don't know what energy
is and of course energy is a concept
it's not a what you can't say you can't
ask the question what is energy because
energy is not a what energy is not like
you say what is the dog and you say here
I'll point to it and that's a dog and
you point to the dog you can't point to
energy there's no such thing as energy
have to say that we came out of energy
well it's it's mathematical nonsense all
right three broman says fascinating
discussion can bill talk about the
origin story of his theory of is how did
it come to him well I just want us
explain it and debating with these guys
I started looking for God for for an
explanation of what am I going to say
the next time someone says prove to me
that God doesn't exist and when I went
to the physicist you know I found out
that these were more religious than the
Christians and the Muslims and so forget
about these guys you know we got a
bigger problem here
Onassis just one thing Carl Sagan was my
hero because he's a great teacher
Fineman I had high regards for finding
two because they were both great
teachers they had a way of communicating
which even beats me you know by a mile
but they communicated nonsense
unfortunately that just says out of the
ropes explain gravitational lensing I
think you did this is a subject that
you'd like to cover yeah very simple
let's just look at Arthur
edingtons verification of Einstein's
theory in 1919 what did Arthur Eddington
do supposedly he went out there was
ships into the ocean and into the
Pacific Ocean and he looked at during an
eclipse he realized that there was a
star behind the Sun and he could see
that star even though the Sun was in the
way and so the question is how did we
see that star behind the Sun
and I explained it very if I had the
graphic that I could show you and you do
a picture's worth a thousand words but
let me see if I can explain it you have
the star every atom in the star is
connected to every atom forming the
corona of the Sun so each one is
connected okay and now each atom in the
corona of the Sun is connected to your
eye so what happens the atoms are being
are relaying the signals from the the
you know the torsion signals from that
star to your eyes through the atoms in
the that form the corona of the Sun so
you can form you can form a curve with
straight lines that's the point
are you saying that it's a failure of
the material to be opaque essentially
these ropes are carrying the light
signal through objects well I'm
wondering are the ropes actually curved
in your models or they are gonna just go
through the object no no no no ropes
ropes always straight oh they curve
around they form the magnetic field that
ropes are always tightly pulled there's
the Rope never bends in any way it's
always pulled tight and what I'm saying
is if you connect one atom to another
atom and that atom to another atom in a
triangular away you can convey that
signal from behind the Sun by the sides
through the sides ah very interesting
okay you do it all with great lines
that's what I'm saying if you know
there's this pattern that you can do
with straight lines and you just keep
turning the straight line you know over
and you can creat a curve and that's
essentially what's happening with with
the rooks
very interesting right that's why light
turns around corners not because light
bent but because we do it always
straight ropes that are connected from
atom to atom it's it's relayed the
signal is relayed nice look at bear says
I like bill gayde Hertz what I think
says great show gentleman and a MIDI
Sameer says
are you broadcasting from a nuthouse
absolutely well it was a pleasure that
you have anything else to explore today
I think I'm going to conclude this show
side by side with least with the wave
and with the particle absolutely I'll be
carrying the exposure of the rope I'll
be I'll be trying to do my best to have
someone really come to me and convince
me that the Rope doesn't think this I'd
love to period personally I've done my
best I think that it recruits elements
of other theories of physics and it puts
them together in such a magical and well
I know I don't take it as an insult I
just used the word magical but I didn't
mean it as an insult but it's almost
it's very special the way in which it
binds gravity light magnetism in ways
that I've never seen before
thank you so much for coming they'll get
all right bye-bye
I just want to do a news show and this
homeless physicist comes there and he
says to me that there is no black hole
at the center of galaxies
I don't know what to think and it was
for you guys who are watching us we will
be doing the patreon hangout tonight
what time is it 8:30 6:00 right now so
let us start the patreon hangout at 9:00
p.m. this will be in 24 minutes from now
if you haven't joined a patreon right
now you can do it and it's at the twenty
dollar level and you will be receiving a
link you have five minutes after the
show to do it because I'll be sending
the link in about 10 minutes from now so
join us tonight for the private hangout
where we will discuss anything that you
want to discuss we'll look at the news
and we'll see what are the future
projects for the public space
everyone have a good day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]